tutti ragazzi benvenuti quest'anno video
sono parigi oggi siamo su niente volevo
che partisse la miss è ridotto
fantastico siamo sul gioco decentrato di
schermo va bene se col suo amblingh da
horror e linguaggio c'è il russo
francese tedesco immagino che l'italiano
non ci si fermi tutti ci hanno cagati
che incredibile amico mio al che 66 shen
coda quando non sei più al milan
fai le traduzioni che un fantastico
nuovo gioco facile normalmente difficile
giochiamo normalmente ragazza bene e fa
il genoa fa più york non è vero alex
kayser schenk presence milan in
champions league
no am ring le d'oro la baby basato su
una storia vera che posti frequenti se
scelgo però solo ordinaria domenica
mattina non dovremmo andare a scuola
quindi posso dormire con un po i tempi
normali te li sei un po mangiati ma ma
non questa volta attenzione la mamma mi
ha svegliato alle otto e trenta e mi ha
detto che avremmo avuto ospiti stasera è
andato alla lista di cibi e mi ha
chiesto di andare a comprare tutto poi
ho sentito qualcuno suonare il
campanello ho pensato che gli ospiti
sono già arrivati così ho guardato fuori
dalla sala ho visto mia madre apre la
porta ma non c'era nessuno lì solo una
luce intensa sono molto impaurito va
bene zio e anch'io dal tuo italiano però
ok va bene sicuramente costi quadri io
non dormo tranquillo buongiorno salve
cosa facciamo qui c'è una serie c'è la
televisione se non parte il grande
fratello giallo horror diminuisce di
potenza bei quadri complimenti non per
il sangue proprio il quadro in sé fa
schifo perchè l'hai appeso c'è una
tovaglia attaccata al muro c'è una porta
che si apre
ci sono mani sul muro buongiorno come ci
siamo arrivati qua
salve lei ce l'ha un dizionario non cela
lezionario bene cos'è è bloccato se
trova una chiave la aprirò se trovi un
cervello penserai anche quello per un
altro discorso
aprirò eccola qua così apriremo perfetto
la chiave della casa le chiavi della
camera poi cos'è questo suono orme orme
passi ma c'è qualcuno li dentro dove il
frigo dentro il frigo punta la porta
permesso c'è qualcuno qui dentro la
porta la apriremo o c'è un qualcosa di
nascosto perché controllo scusi ma che
ora basta così farti fatemi trovare le
chiavi qualcosa per aprire le porte
se vieni avanti ancora ti do un pugno
non ho capito il senso per cosa sbatti
le pieghe il nonna che sbatte le porte
lì
lo spiegano schiena e niente stato
finito la torcia la torcia si è
scaricata c'è il quadro elettrico
rischio di morire folgorato però che ipo
dell'ansia non ho più le batterie sono
nella cassetta se non trovo batterie
ragazzi quindi vi prego batterie la
stanza del dl questo chi ha fatto gioco
immagino sei bellissimo ho bisogno di
capire però le chiavi dove lei messe
signor se scelgo giorno ama questa la
mia chiave la camera di prima come no ap
russell cenco porco demonia parco e
niente chiesa bourque
la tua sorella porta basta ma che è che
il moral i ragazzi non ho capito che gli
sbatte le porte che buca i vetri la
chiave se la troveremo l'apriremo no si
è aperto uno di essi c'è la cucina
perché sembra o drogato o aiuto ocse sta
succedendo la ama e che tipo amnesia che
se non accendi la luce disease minchia
lo schermo è bloccata se trova una
chiave la aprirò troviamo una chiave
mannaia la morte alla maran che era come
prima che finalmente la porta grave e
c'è un'altra porta chiusa non ho capito
ragazzi aiuto sono le stanze di prima
con delle diversità politicamente una
bottiglia bottiglia da ho trovato questa
è una chiave ma chi se ne frega le trovo
dell'acqua serve aspetta che c'è il
quadro e le forme prima o poi dovrò
aggiustare un suo quadro elettrico
perché sono tutto storto il mio peggior
incubo
ma cos'è i bagni segna fatto la
pallonata
non sei giovanni sempre più michael sei
morto grazie grazie a sono poco morto
dove inizia a fantastico sì però mi
scusi non è che può uscire pesci l'ho
disegnato quando cinque anni come
arrivato
salve vorrei scappare se possibile
ave di questa volta non ha preso in base
a cosa spiega signor chen che mi spieghi
ti ubriachi so sto gioco poi giocato le
monde cadiamo adesso spetta si spegne la
candela signori buonasera e non saranno
ti diamo in questo momento con gerry
scotti 90 dai per favore dai
ecco questo non me l'aspettavo premi e
tieni premuto il tasto b perché dovrei
chiudere gli occhi spiegami a questo
serve per toglierti il louvre
ubriachezza per calmarmi
ma non è che quella roba lì è
semplicemente quando non sono calmo
demoni una chiave ma come era chiusa
prima o poi possibile ha visto
paranormal seria o se aperta l'altra
porto infiniti or col demonio e chi t'ha
fatto ma veramente figlio figlio a 0
l'ansia perfetto che bello cesso della
vasca bello tutto per cortesia aprì la
porta la porta non c'è il riflesso nello
specchio
posso lavarmi le mani ho tratto la
chiave della casa fantastico
ecco questo succede quando faccio una
cagata mostruoso e non riesco più a
uscire dal bagno però con un altro
discorso
prego faccia lei
maronna gesù ave maria piena di grazia
signore contesti sia benedetta
la finiamo grazie very good
ok credo di non dover passare di qua e
invece mi sta proprio bene signori
buonasera
sei morto ed è certo cosa devo fare
scusami c'era quello che sono tutte un
po copie di ptc copie nel senso di fare
lo stesso giro più volte però succedono
cose diverse
io vorrei ecco vedi che c'è un quadro
tipo polizia lenti anzi forse si guarda
il quadro il pavimento non mi aiuta giu
ma dai
[Musica]
mi ha veramente uccellato era proprio
una presa per i fondelli di non muovere
la visuale mentre c'era il jump square e
io lo è io la mossi dopo un genio
sono stato un babbo niente jam scadente
jobs che l'integrazione è detto che è
fantastica st parte bravo bravo share
cento a verificare pronto voglio
verificare questo telefono funziona
ancora posso chiamare a casa
accidenti non ricordo alcun numero di
telemann aima dai dicono solo gli ultimi
due 24 89 89 24 un po kringe questa
volta mi ricordo più il numero di
telefono mannaia lo schifo 24 e ho
capito non lo trovo non ce l'ho 13
ignoto numero di telefono così ha
problemi a documenti telefono mentre
alice in giro per casa e cercare di
quadrare i numeri telefono inizia a
pensare che le impronte sanguinanti
possono significare qualcosa
che senso ha ecco 22 niente 22 numeri
dei due master
a questa altro non c'è più il baratro
fantastico 29 seguo tutto lo schifo che
fastidio eh vabbè ci mancava solo questo
però solo in due per adesso marca tua
madre che kakà maiano l'angolino li
mortacci basta merotto è stato è stato
bello però molto bello ragazzo ragazzi
per cortesia ma va basta stato molto
simpatico va bene se qualcuno sa il
numero di terme lo scriva perché non si
può far così però spero che vi sia
piaciuto sono veramente in ansia non
dormo più però con un altro discorso
come al solito video più slanciato punto
mi piace iscritti al canale schiacciata
la campanellina che deriva le notifiche
e noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video ragazzi
[Musica]